im moment nur eine rolle küchen küche
küchenrolle ist das ist das ein
grundrecht küchenrollen aber herr weise
naja es ist ja ist es ja eher was der
ausdruck von was anderem und da gibt es
wieder um solidarität und darum dass es
nicht nur mein selbst geht
wahrscheinlich gab es gerade nicht mehr
so viel küchenrollen vorrätig ende den
jeweiligen geschäft und dann hat eben
und das ist ja genau das gleiche sie am
ende eine entscheidung des des
geschäftes gewesen aber eben zu sagen es
geht hier nicht nur um herrn weise
sondern im zweifel auch noch um ein paar
andere kunden die eine küchenrolle
brauchen oder was auch immer kann halt
nicht ein jetzt auf einmal in zwei
pakete für eine fünfköpfige familie
durch in ordnung er weiß sondern ein
aber ich finde das wichtig ist ein
beispiel aber es ist doch nur der
versuch möglichst in seinem inneren
balance ihren wunsch ihre freiheit ihr
bedürfnis was zu kaufen
in balance zu bringen mit dem bedürfnis
von anderen das auch zu tun das ist doch
das was wir jeden tag machen das machen
wir jeden tag in der familie das machen
wir jeden tag im zweifel beim einkaufen
und das machen wir natürlich in der
politik dann regelsätzen und das ist
eben der unterschied verbindlich für das
ganze land